it's back to the most Unstoppable
assassin action yet but how will fans
feel about the nearly three hour run
time he is the best and worst things
about John Wick chapter 4. one element
of the John Wick series that can proved
divisive is the way it handles
pedestrians shootouts and fight scenes
throughout the franchise often take
place in crowded locations packed with
extras bursts all these onlookers never
react to the Bloodshed happening right
in front of them this isn't an issue in
the first film but all of the sequels
take a more heightened reality approach
to the crowds of civilians several
people can get gunned down close enough
to them to be in the Splash Zone and the
civilians would just keep on dancing to
the music even as bullets fly for some
this is part of the campy fun of the
series for others it is one step too far
removed from reality to avoid breaking
immersion and making the world feel
artificial it can begin to seem like
there are no normal people in the world
of John Wick and that everyone is an
assassin or Works alongside assassins in
the Underworld John wig chapter 4 on the
other sequels and benefit from the
inclusion of more characters outside of
the assassination game to provide
contrast John Wicks to see his wife
Helen and Kane's daughter Mia are normal
civilians but neither of them has a real
presence this issue makes it harder to
buy into the world of John Wick as a
functioning Society with each sequel
amen after the relatively
straightforward and simple first movie
the settings and backdrops of the John
Wick sequels have all been impressive
varied and well integrated into the
action set pieces chapter 4 raises a bar
in stunning fashion by turning the plot
into a full-fledged Globe spawning
Adventure New York City remains an
important location in its latest outing
however the plus also finds John Wick
returning to the Sahara Desert of
chapter 3 to visit the Elder as well as
traveling to Osaka Berlin and even Paris
for The Showdown with the Marquee adding
to the effectiveness of the locations
themselves is the way in which they are
shut the prior John Wick movies are no
slouches when it comes to their visual
Aesthetics but chapter 4 arguably has
the best cinematography of the bunch the
change from the daily muted color
palette to the first movie to the
increasingly more colorful sequels it's
also a welcome progression the first few
movies mostly line up when it comes to
the rules of the universe verse chapter
4 changes a few things up and asks you
to turn a blind eye to the discrepancies
these issues might have something to do
with the original screenwriter Derek
Kolstad being completely uninvolved with
chapter 4 for the first time in the
history of the series one of the biggest
inconsistencies is how easy it is for
Jon to travel this time around a huge
part of chapter 3 is devoted to a
struggle to get from New York City to
Casablanca this requires him to secure
passage from the Resco Roma which
involves them tearing his ticket for a
one-way trip in chapter 4 John Wick
makes the same International Journey off
screen with no mind paid to how he gets
there he travels around the world
without any difficulty despite the
bounty on his head being significantly
higher than ever before it is also
unclear why Jon needs to go to Berlin to
get the support of the Rusk Aroma after
he previously met at their headquarters
in New York City the complete substance
of the director is a specially
conspicuous when she seems like the
perfect person to solve John's specific
problem the John Wick movies always have
strong soundtracks mixing the series
original score by Taylor Bates and Joel
J Richard with pre-existing music to
great effect though there are plenty of
memorable needle drop moments in the
previous films chapter 4 has arguably
the best overall soundtrack of the
entire series Bates and Richard return
as the main composers and reprise The
Familiar themes while ensuring the music
continues to evolve and feel fresh the
needle drop moments between the original
score are A Cut Above the already high
bar set by the series fans are French
electronic music will be especially
thrilled as trucks from popular artists
like gessa folstein and Justice show up
one of the best musical moments in the
entire film was actually a reprise of a
song first due to lies in the original
John Wick the song Led spirals by Lee
Castlevania makes a welcome return to
the soundtrack of chapter 4. after
previously scoring the centerpiece
shoots out that takes place in the red
circle nightclub in the first movie if
there is anything that hurts the action
of John Wick's chapter 4 it is that Jon
feels a bit too Invincible at times part
of the joy of the first John workers how
much pain he suffered and how wounded he
was by the end and yet still came out on
top giving John a bulletproof suit in
Chapter 2 runs a risk of making him too
indestructible but the film finds a way
to balance the scales and keeps a sense
of danger intact by chapter 4 John
begins to feel a bit too superhuman it
really only becomes a major distraction
when it comes to the multiple two to
three story Force he takes and bounces
back from like they're nothing these
land and stark contrast to the fall he
takes from the roof of the Continental
at the end of chapter 3 which requires
substantial time to rest and recover
before he's ready to fight again Jon
takes two huge Falls of a comparable
size in chapter four not to mention the
various other hits stabs gunshots and
hundreds of stairs that he falls down
yet he hardly bats an eye out to the
physical trauma this time around the
stakes of the action feel a little lower
as a result though the very end of the
film course corrects for the better the
John Wick series is almost as much about
dogs as it is about action the murder of
Jon's puppy in the original film is of
course the straw that breaks the camel
back and kicks off his quest for
vengeance each subsequent movie keeps
canines at the part of the series DNA in
chapter 4 a new dog is brought into the
action owned by the tracker aka Mr
Nobody we see this dug in some creative
new ways like running and leaping across
the tops of cars and the shootout set in
front of the Arc de Triomphe the best
moment involving the dog is actually a
choice made by Jon though the dog and Mr
Nobody had been trying to kill him Jon
saves her dog when she is about to be
killed it is a perfect moment of
redemption for John after what happened
to Daisy all the way back in the first
movie
John wig chapter 3 ends with a massive
Cliffhanger after throwing away the
freedom he earned from the high table to
defend Winston John is double crossed
Winston shoots him and sends him off the
roof of the Continental the first three
John Wick movies all take place within a
short time span each one beginning right
after the previous one ended For the
First Time chapter 4 picks up following
an extended Gap in time after John and
the Bowery King are both fully healed
once John is back in Action he only has
his side set on the high table not on
Winston when the two do cross paths John
lets Winston off the hook extremely
easily and the two become chummy again
and spend the rest of the film working
together the promise Vengeance against
Winston never happens nor does Winston
ever truly wreck him with his active
betrayal this is particularly hard to
buy given that one of Jon's defining
character traits is that he can't let
things go and always needs to settle the
score
what have you done chapter 4 brings a
focus back to John's deceased wife Helen
in key moments that are quite effective
and help make the series feel like it is
coming full circle her presence is less
prominence than in the first movie but
far more impactful than it is in the
other sequels and one key scene John
lights a candle and Pays His respects to
her before having a friendly
conversation with Kane about why Jon
says he doesn't believe she can hear him
or feel his presence but he does it
anyway because he could be wrong John's
most vulnerable and human moments in the
entire film arrives when he tells
Winston that he wants his Epitaph to
read loving husband he's an Infamous
assassin with a legendary reputation yet
he only wants to be remembered in
relation to Helen and finally the quick
flash of Helen and Jon's dying moments
is a beautiful way to tie it all
together and provide a fitting
conclusion to Mr Wick's Journey the
first John Wick movie and its first
sequel give Jon a clear goal to work
toward in typically violent fashion
chapter 3 is the first time where Jon's
motivation starts to falter but chapter
4 is a step down in the motivation
Department as Jon doesn't really have a
good reason for the Bloodshed at all
this time around other characters say a
search within the film Winston tells
John that what he's doing is pointless
and won't accomplish anything and he's
right the Marquee calls John a man with
nothing to live for Nothing To Die For
and nothing to kill for and he's also
right the film Embraces this emptiness
in Jon but it is a genuine problem with
the central figure Jon barely feels like
a character anymore in chapter four and
is mostly just a vessel for other
characters to exploit try to kill and
get killed by I'm going to need a gun
John wig chapter 4 introduces many new
characters to the series and they are
all great Chidi Akira The Harbinger
chimazu the tracker Marquee and
especially Kane are all fantastic
additions to the John Wick World Kane
even steals a show from done where can
nearly begins to feel like the main
character himself at points as he takes
Center Stage for stretches where Jon is
absent but both credits scene teases
that he actually might become the
protagonist of his own spin-off at some
point in the franchise's future which
sounds fantastic in theory each film in
the John Wick Series has gotten
progressively longer but the biggest
leap come to John Wick chapter 4. this
new installment is nearly three hours
long on the plus side the longer run
time means more action and the film
fully delivers in that category all the
same the Hefty length is a clear
hindrance too much of a good thing can
still become exhausting the extended
Berlin portion of the plot of chapter 4
is what the length is the most
problematic this segment of the film is
well made but does not feel like an
integral part of the overall story a new
villain is introduced and immediately
killed off in the form of killer a fun
character who unfortunately has no real
purpose in the story the entire Berlin
sequence could theoretically be left on
The Cutting Room floor without affecting
the story and the overall film will be
much tighter and better paced as a
result it would also lose a couple of
new characters which would help chapter
4 feel less overstuffed it should come
as no surprise whatsoever that the best
part of John Webb chapter 4 by far is
the action every John Wick movie has had
to raise a bar and find new ways to
Showcase Mr wedge lethal skill sets
chapter 4 continues to expand the styles
of action on offer by incorporating
exciting new weapons like nunchucks and
bows and arrows and by making one of its
main players Kane a blind assassin with
a unique fighting style the introduction
of dragon's breath shotgun shells for
one's spectacular sequence is a 5V way
to raise a shootout bar higher than it
has ever been before chapter 4 has some
shortcomings in the writing department
but they are easy to overlook when the
action is so incredible
[Music]
um